hay algo de verdad en las estrellas esos
párpados deslumbrantes de la noche
eso saben de mí no sos que tanto en los
grandes de arriba
muchas veces hemos olvidado que estamos
hechos de ese mismo colmo de cuando
explotó el universo que somos una
extensión del primer llanto que el mundo
ha nacido
a veces antes de irme a dormir me gusta
pensar en una empresa con un libro
explosivo sino con un suspiro suave y
lento como las que se deslizan por la
boca de la costa
este pensamiento me acoge y me a rubia
el pensar y estar así tranquilo quieto
profesor suficiente
pero no quiere quedarse quieto mi
corazón es una lancha cruzando el mar
abierto siempre vivo tratando de no
hundirse a veces siento la necesidad de
sumergirse bajo el agua sólo para
recordar lo bonito que es respirar
el problema está cuando crea estar
sumergido y en realidad es sobre la
superficie del encuentro las estrellas
nos comportamos que al mundo en mi
camino dentro de otras personas
sino no poder verla cuando está bien
pensar
no quiero que las calles recuerden mi
nombre
son mis pasos sobre el pavimento y risas
entre sus rincones no quiero que me
gusten emotivos historias son
fotografías en cartas escritas a mano
[Música]
cuando fui parte de todo esto si estoy
atado a una tienda de palabras que se
desvanecerán que quedan escritas sí
estoy condenada a desaparecer como un
truco de magia antes de hacerlo
pero el mundo no va a dejar de universo
cuanta pechos piense mi corazón es una
regla moral de los entrenadores elección
de izapa función de sábado
a días en donde me dan ciudad existen
dimensiones más allá de los cuatro
puntos de mi cama no quiere decir eso ni
me dejan atrás no quiero hacer una
náusea en mi propia soledad perderme en
la inicial para mis pensamientos y nunca
volver a encontrarme no quiero ser un
tesoro escondido que nunca podrá
hallarse a sí misma
estamos creando un best de las
constelaciones para no hacemos más que
eso somos una sonrisa emocionada sus
mensajes enamorados somos manos
entrelazadas
un universo que palpita en el espacio
entre un abrazo
si no encuentras las estrellas del cielo
encontradas en el resplandor a los ojos
de una persona que amas
prometo ya no luchar contra mi misma
naturaleza entendiendo que la existencia
fugaz del humano nunca será suficiente
siempre habrá más por vivir más para
hacer
frente a ustedes los segundos resbalan
de los dedos como arena
pero hambrientos que estoy aquí en este
mundo en este lugar en este momento
i
[Aplausos]